[Musique]
je vais commencer par vous poser une
question pensez vous que vous mangez
bien qui ici a le courage de lever la
main devant une nutritionniste
ah je vois des mains qui se lèvent
c'est intéressant parce que les mains se
lèvent et puis hop
en fait je mange bien mais de temps en
temps je mange des choses que j'aimerais
éviter
j'essaie de me contrôler mais de temps
en temps je dérape
aujourd'hui manger est un vrai casse
tête il y a tellement de règles
tellement d'informations tellement de
sens sans sucre sans gluten un grand
niveau d'anxiété un grand niveau de
culpabilité certaines personnes même
peuvent le vivre comme quelque chose de
dangereux
alors qu'autrefois manger bien c'était
simplement avoir assez à manger alors
nous vivons aujourd'hui une tyrannie
alimentaire une tyrannie nutritionnelle
et nous ne savons plus quoi manger
moi j'ai rencontré cette tyrannie pour
la première fois il y a trente ans quand
je suis parti vivre à new york
je suis arrivé en bonne française en
paix avec l'alimentation et je découvre
une guerre à new york une guerre contre
le gras tout est telle en face au fath
nos cholestérol même les bouteilles
d'eau avait écrit no cholestérol alors
brillé mais que voit-on sur certaines
bouteilles d'eau aujourd'hui sans gluten
et oui cette tyrannie nutritionnelle
elle ne fait que s'amplifier
parce que ça a commencé contre le grain
puis c'était contre des glucides
puis c'était sangsues
sans gluten sans lactose son fructose ça
devient de plus en plus compliqué qu'est
ce que ça veut dire
il ya aussi le sans viande parce que la
viande peut donner le cancer mais aussi
pour des raisons éthiques
il ya aussi le sont les produits
laitiers le sens fruits et légumes à
cause des pesticides
mais que reste-t-il le jeune
intermittents on en est là c'est global
dans mon cabinet de consultation à sao
paulo
les patients arrivent perdu d'auto la
sophie dit moins ce que je dois manger
ils sont à l'affût de connaissances pour
manger moins manger sain maigrir mais a
tous besoin de plus de connaissances
pour manger mieux
il ya un paradoxe aujourd'hui on n'a
jamais eu autant d'information sur la
nutrition
on n'a jamais autant entendu parler de
régime et en même temps on n'a jamais eu
autant de mal être avec l'alimentation
et autant de problèmes de poids
les injonctions nutritionnelle augmente
notre anxiété face à la nutrition et en
fait trop de connaissances nuit à notre
relation avec les aliments
alors qu'on vit une abondance
fantastique alimentaire cet excès
d'anxiété est néfaste pour notre santé
mentale et physique
alors je vais vous demander pendant
quelques instants
je vais vous invitez plutôt à oublier
tout ce que vous savez sur la nutrition
je suis diététicienne nutritionniste et
j'aime manger je suis contre les régimes
et plus j'étudie plus je suis contre les
régimes je suis chef
cher en neurosciences de l'alimentation
neuro sciences du comportement
alimentaire et pour moi le comportement
alimentaire est aussi important que ce
que vous mangez que le nutriment et
parfois même plus comment vous mangez
m'intéresse plus que ce que vous mangez
est-ce que vous perdez le contrôle est
ce que vous avez peur est-ce que vous
avez de la culpabilité
aujourd'hui nous vivons ce terrorisme
alimentaire et il se trouve que j'ai
fait mon doctorat à la fac
de médecine de san paolo en portugais
est large et étudier l'obésité infantile
et la génétique elle est à part de la
génétique dans l'obésité infantile
quelle est la part de l'alimentation
dans l'obésité infantile
et comme tout le monde au début je
voulais aider mes petits patients à
maigrir donc je leur disais bon et mange
de la salade à bouger un peu plus et en
face de moi j'avais des enfants tristes
des enfants perdus qui me disaient mais
d'autres la sophie je ne pense qu'à
manger toute la journée d'auto d'assaut
fille je mange en cachette de ma maman
mais je ne veux pas mais si tu ne veux
pas pourquoi tu le fais c'est plus fort
que moi
et cette phrase c'est plus fort que moi
je l'entendais tout est donc je suis
parti étudier plus et je suis parti en
psychiatrie travailler avec les troubles
du comportement alimentaire
les personnes souffrant d'anorexie de
boulimie de convulsions et une chose
intéressante c'est qu'elles ont toutes
la même histoire
j'allais bien j'ai fait un régime et
j'ai commencé savez vous que presque
tous les troubles alimentaires
commencent avec un régime
notre cerveau déteste les régimes et
notre cerveau c'est notre chef
d'orchestre dans notre cerveau on a les
émotions on a aussi les hormones la fin
et dans le cerveau la satiété et dans le
cerveau notre poids est régulée par le
cerveau quand on fait un régime on
envoie un information de menace à notre
cerveau et notre cerveau va réagir
notre cerveau va se défendre il y à une
modification d'expression des gènes dans
notre cerveau
suit un régime lola
s'ils augmentent et le métabolisme
diminue et c'est pour ça que la majorité
des gens qui font un régime vont maigrir
au début et ensuite reprendre le point
on dit même que c'est 95%
c'est à dire tout le monde ah oui mais
il ya 5 % de réussite
ok je suis allé voir je suis chercheur
qui sont ces 5 % de réussite
en fait c'est une réussite à ne pas
reprendre du poids mais vous savez
qu'ils sont cette réussite ce sont les
troubles alimentaires
je ne considère pas ça une réussite
ce sont des gens qui se retrouvent avec
des maladies psychiatriques de grande
intensité terrain régime bouleverse
notre centre de l'appétit après on n'a
plus d'appétit mais on a aussi plus
d'obsession pour manger on n'est plus la
même personne
on a plus de manger émotionnel je suis
triste je mange je suis anxieux je mange
je suis stressée je mange je suis
contente je mange je m'ennuie je mange
l'acte de manger et physiologique mais
aussi psychologiques et plus vous
essayer de contrôler et plus vous
risquez de perdre le contrôle oui mais
alors qu'est-ce que manger de manière
saine j'ai posé la question à mes
patients ce sont des patients à la fac
de médecine qui souffrent de compulsion
alimentaire et je devais leur faire une
conférence sur l'alimentation saine et
plutôt que de leur donner un cours
j'ai voulu savoir ce qu'ils pensaient de
cette alimentation saine une main timide
s'est levé et m'a dit mais d'autres la
sophie manger sain c'est manger sans
sucre sans sel sans grain pour elle
manger sain ça n'a pas de vous ce n'est
pas bon il n'y a pas de pelé
rires on voit que la nutrition s'est
concentré sur les nutriments la
nutrition s'est concentré sur les
calories on ne mange plus de la viande
et des pâtes manger des protéines et des
glucides le plaisir n'a pas été étudiée
je dirais même que le plaisir est un peu
de diaboliser on a l'impression qu'il
faut choisir où plaisir on santé vous
avez remarqué que tout ce qui est
plaisir n'est pas très sain et tout ce
qui est santé n'est pas toujours très
bon c'est compliqué vous voulez un
gâteau au chocolat et vous allez manger
une pomme parce que c'est ça quel
dommage
la pomme est délicieuse mais vous allez
même pas en profiter
et vous allez rester avec cette
frustration d'avoir voulu le gâteau au
chocolat avec peut-être même une crise
de manger émotionnel en fin de journée
alors c'est intéressant je suis
spécialisé en nutrition est ce que vous
croyez que je pense que le gâteau au
chocolat fait grossir
et bien non ça va dépendre de comment
vous allez le manger en 80 dont les
années 90 un grand sociologue français
claude fischler et son ami psychologue
américain hors pôles rosine ont décidé
d'essayer de percer le secret des
françaises
et oui les françaises elles mangent des
gâteaux elle mange du grain ils boivent
du vin
ils sont
plutôt plus minces ce que les
américaines
alors quel est le secret des françaises
et c'était intéressant parce que leurs
études n'étaient pas sûres ni les
coloris ni les nutriments mais sur les
pensées et émotions que l'on ressent
quand on mange alors ils ont élaboré une
liste d'aliments et ils leur ont demandé
que pensez vous quand vous entendez ce
mot poulet carottes le plus intéressant
était justement le gâteau au chocolat
les américaines dans leur grande
majorité ont répondu un gâteau au
chocolat oui alors grossir gras
culpabilité et ce qui est intéressant
c'est que les françaises dans les années
90 ont répondu dans grande majorité
heureuses fêtes anniversaires plaisir
c'est le même gâteau au chocolat
mais l'émotion est très différente celle
qui vit dans la culpabilité
elle va d'abord résisté à ce gâteau elle
va dire ah non non non je peux pas
manger de gâteau au chocolat ça fait
grossier et puis à un moment naturel où
elle va dire bon je mérite je vais
manger seulement ce moment l'un c'est un
moment un peu de tout rien hein ce
gâteau va être avalé avec ici une boule
de culpabilité mon dieu quelle je fais
et puis ce raisonnement de foutu pour
foutu je vais faire un dernier repas de
gâteau au chocolat
je vais à manger encore 1 et encore 1
puisque deux mains je reprends mon
régime alors maintenant penser à l'autre
qui n'a pas cette culpabilité et qui en
fait une fête d'abord elle va choisir le
mais le plus beau le plus beau gâteau
et puis va s'asseoir il ya va le
savourer elles ont fait une fête et
cette première bouchée c'est la
meilleure de toute cette première
bouchée elle parle avec tout vos
papilles gustatives et l envoi à votre
cerveau l'information que la vie ben que
la vie vaut la peine
mais le palet s'habitue la deuxième
boucher est déjà moins intéressante elle
reste très agréable mais au bout de
trois quatre bouchers la personne est
satisfaite et de même elle sait qu'elle
peut en manger demain si elle veut pas
besoin de faire ses derniers repas alors
vous voyez que en fait le plaisir la
santé vont de pair il se trouve que
quand on mange avec plaisir peut-être on
va manger un petit peu plus dans leurs
pas parce qu'on va se resservir
c'est tellement bon mais au long de la
journée
on va être tellement satisfait qu'on
finit par manger moins je travaille avec
des patients qui souffrent d'obésité des
patients qui souffrent de troubles du
comportement alimentaire
donc je peux être le matin avec un petit
enfant obèse et l'après midi avec une
jeune fille anorexique et vous devez
vous dire où l'alors c'est compliqué
parce qu'alain il faut dire de manger
moins l'autre faut dire de manger plus
et en fait non le discours est presque
le même faire la paix avec
l'alimentation faire la paix avec le
corps faire la paix avec soi même je
défends qu'on peut manger de tout mais
pas tout ce qui se présente modérément
bien manger c'est manger de tout sans
restriction sans culpabilité avec
plaisir
et en respectant sa fin et ses émotions
je dis qu'il faut manger mieux et non
pas moins manger mieux
ça veut dire avec plus de conscience
avec un meilleur comportement
alimentaire est aussi une meilleure
qualité alimentaire la qualité
alimentaire ce n'est pas sans gras sans
sel sans sucre aujourd'hui ce qu'on voit
c'est que la qualité alimentaire
c'est plutôt frais faits maison et moins
industrialisés - transformer des études
récentes nous montre que les aliments
ultra transformés ont un effet sur notre
appétit sur notre poids sur notre santé
d'autres études à harvard nous montre
que la meilleure protection contre
l'obésité et le diabète de type 2 c'est
cuisiner manger fait maison
alors après toutes ces années de
recherche
j'ai trois conseils pour vous oubliez
les régions manger plus frais et faits
maison - transformé cuisine et la
science de la nutrition est très
complexe mais bien manger relativement
simple nos grands-parents le faisait
sans difficulté sable ne veut pas dire
facile mais essayons d'oublier ces
injonctions nutritionnelle et permettons
nous de manger n'ayez pas n'ayez pas
envie de vouloir connaître plus
d'information sur la nutrition
essayez d'éviter ces applicatifs et
applications sur les portables
il faut être plus connectés avec soi
même penser - et savoir moins sentir
plus
et savourer bon appétit
[Applaudissements]